hey everybody it's Gary vaynerchuk super
excited to talk about my new book day
trading attention how to actually build
brand sales in the new social media
world really this is a followup to jab
jab jab right hook get over here um in a
lot of ways if you read this this is
kind of the 301 and 10 years later
update how do you do content but this
one's even greater I really want content
there whereas this one goes into media
it goes into influencer it goes into a
lot of other things really the ad
advancements of the biggest conversation
which is if you are not a day trader of
attention AKA where do people pay
attention predominantly screens like
this and screens like this and and do
you actually know how to tell stories in
it AKA do you understand how to make
content for it contextually the
difference between a Carousel and a Reon
do you understand the first three
seconds of the video matter the
thumbnail what time to post all that
nerd stuff the science behind the art of
making videos pictures and audio
recordings across the 10 to 15 platforms
that matter most in the world whether
you're the CEO of a Fortune 50 company
or you're a Creator whether you own
three pizza shops or you're a B2B
executive in sales and SAS the LinkedIn
the YouTube the Facebook the Twitter the
Instagram the X Twitter all of it all in
one book I'm pretty proud of this ROV
big shout out to you uh worked with me
very closely on 12 and a half and now
working on this really the marketing
book for 2024 that everybody on Earth is
going to get value out of it that is
what we went into it with and I've got
to say and I've done this a long time
now pretty excited about this one I
think this one's going to have a huge
impact and I hope you check it
[Music]
out